MSNBC: The global order is being utterly transformed.
Marsh McLennan: If we are more adaptive, imaginative,
and collaborative in our approaches to preparedness
and resilience, we’ll be able to better
anticipate and respond to emerging risks.
TIME: We will not leave our future vulnerable
to the whims of those who do not share our
vision for a world that is free, open, prosperous,
and secure.
CNBC Television: We meet tonight at an inflection
point.
One of those moments that only a few generations
ever face, where the direction we now take
is gonna decide the course of this nation
for decades to come.
Gabrielle SIERRA: Hey everyone, we’ve returned!
We ended our last season of Why It Matters
with an episode that looked back over 2022.
This season, we’re starting out by looking
ahead.
It’s something think tanks spend a lot of
time doing - scanning the horizon, searching
for emerging threats, and thinking about how
to prepare for them.
Lucky for me, I work around a lot of people
who are very good at this.
In fact, every year the Council publishes
a report called the Preventive Priorities
Survey.
It’s a little bit like those top ten lists
you find all over the Internet, except instead
of songs from the ‘90s it rates global threats
to the United States.
This year, there are thirty threats on the
list, including seven so-called Tier 1 threats.
For years, the survey was dominated by concerns
about terrorism.
But now the 9/11 era has receded into the
rearview mirror, and we’re moving into a
new phase, one that’s going to require entirely
new strategies.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It
Matters.
Today, I speak with the author behind the
survey, Paul Stares, about what we might face
in 2023, and the nature of predictions in
a turbulent world.
Paul STARES: So this is something that we've
been doing now for fifteen years.
The wonky name for it would be a crowdsource
risk assessment, but essentially, it's a survey
of several thousand American foreign policy
experts.
SIERRA: Aside from leading the PPS Report,
Paul is the senior fellow in conflict prevention
here at CFR.
He also oversees an interactive tool called
the Global Conflict Tracker.
You should check it out.
STARES: We develop a list of thirty contingencies,
which are sort of potential scenarios related
to ongoing conflicts, could they get worse?
Or new conflicts, could they break out?
And we ask each of the respondents of the
survey to do two things: to rate the likelihood
in the coming year, as well as the impact
on U.S. foreign policy interests or national
security interests.
And we organize them into three tiers or levels
of relative priority or importance.
The idea being essentially that not all potential
crises or conflicts are equally important-
SIERRA: Are created equal, sure.
STARES: ...and we should pick and choose and
prioritize what we're doing.
So, that's the survey.
SIERRA: And what's your batting average like?
STARES: So, it's actually pretty good, but
I always have a mixed feeling saying that
because that's more or less saying the world
is getting more conflict prone, and it's like,
"Oh, my god, the worst happened!"
SIERRA: Do you feel like you accurately predicted
some of the things that we saw this past year?
STARES: I think we had ten contingencies in
the top tier.
I think eight out of those ten all happened.
The one we're always asked about is, "Did
you anticipate Ukraine?"
And our respondents gave an even chance.
But because they also said if it were to happen
this would be a pretty serious consequential
high impact event.
So, the combination meant that it became a
tier one.
So, if the goal here is really to flag potential
sources of conflict that could be harmful
to U.S. interests to make policymakers focus
on them, we did the job.
SIERRA: And my last question about the survey
itself before we move on to the threats: what
ultimately is the end goal?
How are these predictions used?
STARES: So, one of the recurring criticisms
of U.S. foreign policy and crisis management
is that we're too reactive.
We get blindsided by events that we don't
see coming or there was intelligence and we
just neglected to take notice of it.
And as a result, crisis hits, and we are suddenly
scurrying around, our hair is on fire.
What do we do?
And we might react in a hasty fashion, possibly
in a way that is actually ultimately counterproductive
to our interests.
So, the goal of this is to try to anticipate
what could happen.
And on the basis of that, you try to take
some both preventive measures and precautionary
measures.
The idea of this survey is to try to help
busy policymakers make choices between different
demands.
SIERRA: And the demands are pretty intense.
I mean, as we said earlier, the PPS itself
landed on 30 major contingencies, and there
were dozens of others that didn’t make the
cut.
We can’t cover them all in a single episode,
so, in no particular order, we’re going
to focus on the report’s Tier 1 threats.
Each of these seven high-impact scenarios
was determined to have at least a moderate
chance of occurring in the next year.
Buckle up.
Contingency One.
CNBC: Beijing - taking steps to increase its
military pressure on Taiwan, carrying out
now regular, amphibious assault exercises
and military in-spy flights over the nation.
BBC News: Taiwan is to extend compulsory military
service from four months to one year to counter
threats from China.
CNBC: If something happens in Taiwan, we are
in trouble.
SIERRA: An escalation over Taiwan.
SIERRA: It kind of feels like Taiwan is the
thing that gets talked about more often than
anything else in our building.
It’s this super complex situation with a
lot of ins and outs.
But I wanted to lead with the simplest question:
are we looking at a possible war with China?
STARES: Could be.
Last year was particularly scary because China
upped the military exercises and missile tests
in the vicinity of Taiwan.
They were pretty mad at the U.S. suggesting
that we would treat Taiwan as a treaty ally
when it's not technically that, and we don't
have what we would call official relations.
But then, Speaker Pelosi visited and that
seemed to signal that our attitudes to Taiwan's
status have changed, and so China wanted to
send a pretty strong signal.
And so the number of military incursions into
Taiwan's airspace increased.
They started lobbing missiles within the vicinity
of Taiwan.
It was pretty intimidating.
And you think, well, are they really going
to attack?
Probably not.
But you think, well, there could be an accident,
there could be some miscalculation, misunderstanding
about what's going on.
And so the risk of conflict definitely went
up, and I think this is something that is
truly serious, and if it were to happen, the
implications would be enormous.
SIERRA: Wow.
Okay.
Well, that's the first one.
We're only on one.
STARES: It doesn't really get better.
SIERRA: The Taiwan problem involves everything
from the state of global democracy to the
semiconductor business.
While tensions eased a bit after the Trump
years, the recent flare-up over a Chinese
spy balloon shows just how quickly dynamics
can change between the world’s two most
powerful countries.
Let’s be clear here - a war between the
United States and China could mean a conflict
on a scale we have not seen since World War
II.
For one thing, both sides have nukes.
And even without that risk, a battle between
superpowers could lead to mass casualties,
chaos in the global economy, and humanitarian
crises.
We’re actually going to break down the whole
situation in another episode this season,
so stay tuned.
In the meantime, on we go.
Contingency Two.
CNN: The U.S. and its allies believe the Russians
could mount a massive offensive once the spring
comes.
That’s why the Ukrainians are getting their
forces ready even as they’re already fighting
the Russians on several fronts in this country.
ABC News: The war in Ukraine spilling over
the border into Poland, a NATO ally of the
U.S.
ABC News: The reality is that Putin has said
he’s prepared to use nuclear weapons, he
has over 5,000 nuclear weapons at his disposal,
and he’s already using the threat to prevent
or deter the United States and NATO from getting
more heavily involved in Ukraine.
SIERRA: The war in Ukraine gets worse.
STARES: So, foreign policy wonks, when they
talk about escalation, they often make a distinction
between vertical escalation, an intensity
of the conflict and what kind of weapons are
used.
And so, there was a lot of concern last year
about the possible use of nuclear weapons
by Russia, tactical nuclear weapons, battlefield
nuclear weapons, which sound like not such
a big deal, but it is a big deal.
Thousands of people could still die-
SIERRA: Absolutely.
STARES: ...and radioactive, environmental
and so on.
And it could escalate even further from that.
So, that's one kind of escalation.
The other one is called horizontal escalation,
which means that it could spread geographically.
And here, the concern was that Russia might
choose to distract the U.S. and NATO and put
pressure on, say, the Baltic states, and the
war could spread there or into Belarus, which
neighbors Ukraine, or there'd be some kind
of accident.
And there was, actually.
There was a missile that hit Poland, and instead
of this war being contained to Ukraine, it
actually spreads and becomes a much bigger
deal.
SIERRA: As a side note, the missile that hit
Poland last November turned out to be part
of Ukraine’s own air defense - and as a
result, NATO escalation was averted.
But the incident does show how precarious
things can get in the fog of war.
If Russia were to attack a NATO member this
year, Article 5 of NATO’s treaty would compel
the other allies to act – pulling the U.S.
directly into the fray.
As antagonism continues to mount in 2023,
the chance for the conflict to escalate remains
very real.
Contingency three.
TODAY: This morning we’re learning more
about an alarming rise in cyberattacks targeting
key U.S. institutions.
TODAY: This morning, a new urgent warning
from the federal government about the rising
cyber threat against the nation’s schools.
SkyNews Australia: The majority of cybersecurity
experts and four in five business leaders
fear a catastrophic cyber event is likely
in the next two years.
SIERRA: A cyber attack on critical U.S. infrastructure.
STARES: Yeah.
This is always tough to evaluate because there
are no warning signs of this potentially happening,
and we've had states meddle in our political
system.
Remember back in 2016, was it, when Russia
was found to be meddling and running an influence
campaign in the U.S. Here, the primary concern
is that a bunch of hackers, possibly with
the support of a government, and we often
finger Russia or Iran, or North Korea, could
disable critical networks used for banking,
used for healthcare, transportation, our energy
system.
They may have even embedded certain software
in the system already.
There's a big fear that they could just activate
it and suddenly everything goes down.
You won't be able to get money out of your
ATM, you won't be able to get an appointment
at a hospital.
Your power goes out.
And so, there's this latent fear.
People just feel that we are exposed to that
as an open society and there are plenty of
smart people who can do bad things to us.
SIERRA: And that we're not prepared.
STARES: I think in certain sectors we've gotten
better.
I think our banking is more resistant now.
We have backup systems.
I think our energy is more protected now.
But I still think there are other areas.
And frankly, these systems are so complicated
and intertwined, we actually don't know until
the worst happens how meddling in one area
or interference in one area could somehow
spread in this cascade.
And so, yeah, we can think we can self-contain
this.
But it could spread.
SIERRA: Unlike the first two contingencies,
a major cyberattack doesn’t necessarily
point to war between superpowers, in fact
one of the many unknowns surrounding this
contingency is whether or not it could lead
to real-world conflict.
And that’s the thing, there’s no playbook
when it comes to major cyberattacks on infrastructure.
It's all still really new.
We don’t know when or where it might happen,
how far the problem could spread, and how
much economic and human damage it might cause.
Contingency four.
Good Morning America: Federal officials have
reported a record number of encounters on
the U.S.-Mexico border in the last year, and
there are new concerns that it could soon
increase.
CBC News: Gunfire, flames, chaos as a crack
down on a drug cartel spilled into the streets
throughout Sinaloa.
NBC News: Growing unrest in Peru, after violent
protests erupted over the weekend.
MSNBC: For many families in Central America
it is a choice between migration and starvation.
SIERRA: Escalating unrest and violence in
Latin America, fueling a surge in migration
to the United States.
STARES: The fear here is that, and it has
different components, that instability, political
instability, drug related violence, gang violence
in Mexico, could essentially create another
surge of migrants toward the southwest border
and put pressure on us.
I'm not sure, it means necessarily intervention,
but it's just something that people perceive
to be a real source of concern.
And we've seen the president was down in Mexico
recently.
Vice President Harris also has been working
on this, and I think it's a general understanding
that until the situation is stabilized there,
they're just going to keep coming to America.
The other interesting aspect is that Central
America has become - Mexico - is more vulnerable
to serious weather-related events and that
can also cause migrants to head north too.
SIERRA: In 2022, there were 2.38 million encounters
with undocumented immigrants at the U.S.-Mexico
border.
This broke the previous annual record by nearly
1 million.
As Paul said, if unrest continues across Latin
America, people are going to keep arriving
at the border.
And as the surge in crossings continues to
stretch our immigration infrastructure to
its limits, the humanitarian crisis could
worsen.
At the same time, it would exacerbate political
conflict over immigration in the United States.
Contingency Five.
ABC News: Resistance is growing inside Russia
against the war in Ukraine.
NBC News: Protests, tonight, across Russia.
Guardian News: *chanting* “No to war.”
NBC News: In more than fifty cities, Vladimir
Putin - unbound.
CNN: The Russian economy is deteriorating.
There are more and more dead bodies coming
to Russia.
CNN: The attitude of people in Russia is fear.
SIERRA: Civil unrest in Russia due to the
decreasing popularity of the war in Ukraine.
STARES: This is a new one this year, and I
think it comes from the sense that Russia's
policy aggression toward Ukraine is really
unsustainable and it's going to be a kind
of blowback amongst the public about people
dying, the effect of Western sanctions on
people, and that there's going to be more
and more demonstrations and pressure for change.
It could also be more of a top-down kind of
development, being that the people around
President Putin also come to the same conclusion
that this is not in Russia's interest or their
own personal interest and just decide that
he has to go.
That can be done peacefully.
Like “Here's the door of Vladimir, go through
it,” or it could be something more violent
- and Russia's had both in the past.
And as a result, there could be a change in
the leadership of Russia.
Of course, that could be a good thing.
And as much as it might lead to the end of
the war in Ukraine and possibly a better relationship
with the West, could also be a bad thing because
the leader of Russia, like the President of
the United States, is in control of nuclear
weapons.
Who has the finger on the button in this situation
could lead to someone that is even worse than
Putin, more nationalistic, more aggressive.
So, it could go in different ways here, which
I think makes people very nervous.
SIERRA: Over the course of the war with Ukraine,
Putin has clamped down on unrest, detaining
thousands of people and causing tens of thousands
of others to flee the country.
All in all, he has effectively stifled media
coverage and controlled the narrative.
But as the war drags on, Putin has no guarantee
that he will be able to maintain this control.
He could also find himself in the middle of
a power struggle among Moscow elites, including
military hawks who feel the Russian campaign
hasn’t gone far enough.
The outlook is uncertain, and the stakes are
incredibly high.
Contingency Six.
CNBC Television: North Korea launched a powerful
ballistic missile over Japan, one that’s
capable of carrying a nuclear warhead.
TODAY: It appears to be North Korea’s most
powerful missiles yet.
Reuters: The North state media quoted Kim
as saying his country needed to “secure
overwhelming military power.”
Arirang News: A senior U.S. intelligence advisor
says the North will continue to build on its
nuclear leverage this year, with more provocations
and the testing of new weapons.
SIERRA: A crisis stemming from North Korea’s
nuclear weapons program.
STARES: North Korea has been developing nuclear
weapons for many, many years, and they've
tested I think six weapons now.
And so, they have a weapons capability.
They've also been developing delivery systems,
missiles primarily.
What has alarmed a lot of Americans is that
it's not just short range or medium range
missiles, it's long range, intercontinental
range that can hit the United States.
And that has a couple of implications.
One, obviously we are now at risk of being
attacked if someone crazy in Pyongyang, the
capital of North Korea decides to do that.
It also means that our deterrent relationship
with South Korea and Japan is also now in
doubt because people think, are we really
going to risk Los Angeles to defend Seoul,
the capital of South Korea or Tokyo?
And that could be used to coerce us.
Or some accident might happen.
They're launching these missiles with incredible
regularity and flying over Japan.
What happened if one went off course?
SIERRA: Yeah.
It's pretty scary.
STARES: Would war happen?
Maybe.
Maybe not.
I wouldn't count against it.
People would say, "Hey, enough.
We’ve got to deal with this guy and we're
off to the races with a potential new war
in Northeast Asia."
SIERRA: Even though North Korea’s nuclear
capabilities may feel like old news, the continuing
threat has driven neighboring countries in
East Asia to up their defense spending.
Japan has begun rapidly remilitarizing and
South Korea is beginning to consider developing
nuclear weapons themselves, after years of
refusing to do so.
To paraphrase a guest on our first-ever episode:
the world may have grown jaded about the nuclear
threat, but the weapons are still there.
For the curious, we’ll be doing an episode
on just that subject later this season.
Contingency Seven.
CBS Mornings: Conflict between Iran and Israel
dramatically escalated overnight.
CBS News: Israel is reportedly behind a drone
strike on an Iranian military plant over the
weekend.
WION: Iranian media claims that the country
has increased its enrichment of uranium to
60%.
WION: The United States and Israel are holding
their most significant military exercises
to date.
CNN: And among its target audiences for the
messaging is Iran.
SIERRA: A military confrontation between Israel
and Iran over its nuclear weapons program.
STARES: Iran is known to be interested in
developing a nuclear weapons capability.
It says it doesn't intend to do that, but
it's clearly developing the means to do that.
And there's some evidence that it's been researching
how to actually weaponize nuclear energy and
this makes people very nervous for the same
reason we are nervous about nuclear weapons
in the hands of the North Koreans.
How might the Iranians use this?
I'm not saying actually attack someone with
nuclear weapons, but again, using that to
coerce or intimidate.
And the country most affected and most concerned
in the region is Israel.
And there's been a speculation in the past
that Israel would never allow Iran to go nuclear
and that they would destroy the nuclear facilities
and do everything to prevent Iran from acquiring
that capability.
And for the last, I don't know, five, six
years, there's been this kind of secret war
in which Israel has targeted Iranian scientists
and trying to deny them the know-how, if you
will, to slow down their program.
And then, that puts the U.S. in a difficult
situation.
Do we support Israel in that?
I think the chances are that we would because
it's not in our interest either.
But we are talking about, potentially, a very
big attack on Iran that could spread.
Iran could retaliate in places like Lebanon,
on the Israeli border, in Syria, elsewhere.
You know, Iran is already providing Russia
with drones to help them in the war in Ukraine.
So, the potential for Iran to do a lot of
mischief, not only in the region but outside
is very high.
So, things are coming to a head.
There were hopes that the JCPOA, this is the
Iran nuclear deal, would be renegotiated after
President Trump withdrew from it for reasons
we don't quite understand.
But that has so far not succeeded.
And later this year, the agreement, more of
an informal agreement over restraining Iran's
missile systems also comes to an end and that
could be another reason for a crisis.
So, a lot of concern about a potential Israel-Iran
crisis in the region.
SIERRA: Well, Iran's been in the news over
this last year because of internal unrest.
Do you think that the government will be distracted
or switch its focus?
STARES: Great question.
There's been a lot of unrest.
Many Iran watchers think this is the end of
the regime.
I'm not quite as optimistic of that.
But if the momentum of these protests increase
that will put pressure on the regime, that
could create internal stresses in the regime,
and it could collapse.
It could make them even more hard line and
they begin to use extreme force.
But it could also, maybe, conduct activities
outside of Iran designed to distract or to
create a crisis that would somehow undermine
the protestors and they would feel that they
have to, to use a term, “rally around the
flag.”
So all those things are possible.
SIERRA: And there you have your top seven,
rounded out by the threat of war with Iran
over its nuclear program.
Yikes.
With threats like these, it’s no wonder
that Paul has developed such a zen-like demeanor,
given that he has to think about this stuff
every single day.
As is the case with Taiwan and several others,
many of these crises seem to have the potential
to pull the United States into conflict overseas.
Not with rogue terrorist groups, or weak states,
but with powerful countries, many of whom
wield nuclear weapons.
SIERRA: Do you see any themes that jump out
to you across these top threats?
STARES: I think the most interesting takeaway
from this year's survey was not on the survey.
For the first time in fifteen years, there
wasn't a 9/11 contingency, a mass casualty
terrorist attack against the U.S.
And for many years after 9/11, we were so
preoccupied with the terrorist threat.
But this year, that wasn't even proposed to
be included in the survey, yet let alone in
the survey.
And many of the other places around the world
that preoccupied us after 9/11 for twenty
years: Afghanistan, Iraq, Syria, terrorist
activity in parts of Africa.
Until relatively recently, these were the
top concerns of the U.S. foreign policy statute.
They're nowhere to be seen, or rather they're
really low down now in terms of priorities.
So, it's why I think that the 9/11 era is
now over.
And so, to me that is probably one of the
big takeaways.
SIERRA: So now, I guess I have to ask, what
era are we currently in?
STARES: Well, most foreign policy experts
call it the new era of great power competition.
PolicyED: Great power competition.
Forbes Breaking News: Great power competition.
STARES: That's the term you hear all the time
in Washington, it's the buzzword.
GPC, Great Power Competition is the acronym.
Sometimes people just talk about strategic
rivalry with major powers.
But great power competition is what we seem
to be moving into.
SIERRA: The term Great Power Competition,
or GPC, can seem a bit wonky, but it’s actually
pretty simple.
For many decades after World War II, a lot
of experts thought that we may have finally
left behind the part of human history where
powerful, highly developed nations fought
wars with each other.
That notion seems to be changing, and conflict
and war between powerful countries is back
on the table.
Think of places like the U.S., China, Russia,
European powers, India, etc.
STARES: The big question is, "Is it going
to be the last time?"
I.e.
the Cold War?
And people say, "Well, if it's like the last
one, we can deal with that through military
deterrence, through diplomacy, arms control,
things like that."
Other people say, "No, actually, it may not
be like the last time because there are more
players now on the scene.”
And so, this is a more complex era, and you
could also see considerable shifts in the
relative standing of the major powers.
And that traditionally has been associated
with a lot of instability, rising power, people
get worried about it, but you also have declining
powers.
And here, obviously, people think of Russia
becoming like a rogue state and being a source
of tension and conflict.
So, we could be in a very different era to
the Cold War.
The other big question I think your listeners
would be interested in is, "If tensions are
rising amongst the major powers, how are we
going to cooperate on these other big issues?"
SIERRA: You're jumping to my...
STARES: Climate, another pandemic, runaway
artificial intelligence.
There's all kinds of horrific scenarios that
you can dream up, right?
Biodiversity loss, collapse of the ocean systems.
I think this is probably one thing that everybody
agrees on, is that you can only deal with
these problems through broad international
cooperation.
And unless the major powers are leading the
way, that's going to be hard.
So, on the one hand you see increasing friction,
competition, rivalry, even conflict, yet the
world needs more cooperation.
So, how are we going to reconcile that?
And that I think is probably one of the biggest
questions moving forward.
SIERRA: What role do you think that climate
change did play on the survey, and what you're
looking towards over the next year?
STARES: It's really interesting this year
because in previous years, we always got questions
saying, "Why aren't you assessing climate
change?"
And I'd say, "I would love to do that, but
it's really difficult to define a discrete
series of events in which something related
to the climate, a hurricane or a drought or
some severe weather event causes conflict.
And it's just too simplistic a relationship."
But at the same time, it's clear that the
environment, climate change is now having
an effect on the risk of conflict.
It's what is sometimes called a risk magnifier
or a stressor.
And so, this year, I think probably for the
first time we saw three or four of the contingencies
explicitly referring to climate-related or
environmental-related factors as a contributor
to conflict.
And that ain't gonna go away.
We're going to see more of that in the coming
years and particularly in Africa, which is
probably the most vulnerable, maybe in South
Asia with water and typhoons, Southeast Asia,
and Central America.
And this could be, as you say, one of the
defining concerns of our age, but to deal
with that, we're going to need cooperation
amongst the major powers.
So, at the same time, we're at loggerheads
over Ukraine and Taiwan.
Can we compartmentalize things, ring fence
them, how are we going to do this?
SIERRA: I was going to say no, I don't think
so.
I mean, I think exactly that, there's this
focusing on great power competition.
Do you think there is a risk of overlooking
things like, let's say, climate change or
even problems that are building in other areas
of the world?
STARES: I think there's definitely a risk
that there's such bipartisan pressure to be
tough on Russia and China and we know why,
we understand why that is.
No one can excuse what Russia's done in Ukraine
or the intimidating aggressive tactics of
Beijing.
But at the same time, we've got to figure
out a way to, you either compartmentalize
things, you come to some understanding that
there are certain existential problems, life-or-death
issues that we have to deal with and we're
going to put the other stuff to the side and
focus on this.
And to some people, the need to do this is
so strong that it will happen.
I'm less optimistic because human nature can
be frankly self-defeating and irrational.
And so, I'm not totally sure that we will
strike that bargain and separate these things.
So I hope I'm wrong, but-
SIERRA: Yes.
Break the streak.
STARES: Human nature is not always so rational
and benign, so-
SIERRA: Well, hopefully when we speak to you
next season, everything on your list will
be amiss and if not, at least we're better
prepared for what's to come this year.
STARES: Amen.
SIERRA: Thank you for joining us, Paul.
STARES: You're very welcome.
SIERRA: Forecasting is an inexact science,
but it’s also a necessary one, especially
when it comes to international relations.
It pays to be aware, and it pays to have a
plan.
But the PPS is only a snapshot of the risks
as they exist now.
And if there's one thing we've learned in
recent years, it's that global conditions
can shift rapidly.
Whatever happens, we'll be here, watching
right alongside you.
For resources used in this episode and more
information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters and
take a look at the show notes.
If you ever have any questions or suggestions
or just want to chat, email us at whyitmatters@cfr.org
or hit us up on Twitter at @CFR_org.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The opinions expressed on the show are solely
that of the guests, not of CFR, which takes
no institutional positions on matters of policy.
The show is produced by Asher Ross and me,
Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Our associate podcast producer is Molly McAnany.
Our interns this semester are Emily Pace and
Rebecca Rottenberg.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
Noah Berman and Kali Robinson.
Our theme music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
We’d also like to thank Richard Haass, Jeff
Reinke and our co-creator Jeremy Sherlick.
You can subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts,
Spotify, Stitcher, or wherever you get your
audio.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you soon!